mình nếu mà đồng tình năm nay mà đồng tình kìa đồ
và mình phải tìm cách nào đó
phụ họ mới đặc nè của mình
phụ họ mới tính chắc công mở của mình nó đã em ăn mình xin loại
thì đi đang sử dụng bộ đông xin loại của VIP
có phụ họ cho các bạn chẽ
những lần những hộm lưng khảnh y cây đi
cho bộ đông xin loại của VIP nó sẽ có 2 sánh khoảng
đó chính là cái khảnh chữa xuất
và cũng như là chẻ thân thái VIP cóst khác
vối lợi ở cộng lại tới chính giống nhà phòng chăm
là nó tình kìa đi biết đến một cái khoảng thông mình như vậy
thì chăm nó không cần là cái nó chỉ là cái tình loại
mà lúc nào nó rất là cộng đường khác
phát biển mất lợi rất là tất lỗi tự tự tự
lợi hảnh sau với để tìm trong trải thần khoảng
vì mình là một người rất là sức trách phân
là mình sẽ luôn quan tập lý vị
là khách phát của mình như thế nào
mình cũng đi trà vô rất nhiều nữa
là thẻ thân thái thái cầu
quan khách VIP là một cái lợi trọng
nó có thể mọi thứ gì?
Thẻ thân thái VIP có khách không được điều mà kìa đi
nó có thức lột
là chính là kìa đi dụng thể để thân thái nạn lại
và được thái nạn tình rất nằm phần chăm
trước đây nghe nó thể tính dụng được khoảng tình
thôi mà giờ tế
thân thái nạn một sắm thực tế
cũng được khoảng tình nữa
kẹn nhát mọi dầy cũng mình được tự tình loại hài lầm
Phòng trong những cái nhớ tảy phá mà kìa đi lợi trọng
là mình kìa đi được tất lý vạn mình nơi kích hả
một phòng là vì đánh hát nhắc nhắn mình khi bông mình
là mình đang sài tình cũng mình
và mình cũng phải suy nghĩ là việc
mình khi tình như thế nào
thật sự lắm của là một cái đệng giữ đó rất là đặc biệt
bánh thân của kìa đi được khi đi rất là thất lộ
mà gọi là
này phòng mình
thì nó mọi người bố bố bố bố bố bố bố nơi phải
hữu ngay một đôi
đừng là bố VIP để mọi người có một chí kẻ
mà chân Rên AI với cái hình cũng mình
một cái gì đó đặc biệt cho chính bản thân của mình